I've always been really passionate
about the challenge of thinking forward
on what our things are made
out of that we use every day.
I do like to create something
that speaks for itself,
so somebody can look at it
and see the craftsmanship
that goes into it,
and also make them think about
how it was created and why,
what the motivation is?
And that keeps me inspired to
really push the ball forward
in terms of how a surfboard is made.
We're surfers, we're in the ocean,
and we have a reverence for
the place that we're in.
I think it's kind of paying
homage to that as well.
Surfboard sales, particularly
in the last few years
have absolutely gone through the roof.
And that's both a good
thing and a bad thing.
It means that there's probably three times
as many surfers in the water now,
which means three times as many surfboards
that are made from
unsustainable materials,
like fossil fuels, oils, resins,
things that are actually
used to make most surfboards.
And so, people have been
exploring original material
for building surfboards like wood
in really innovative and unique ways.
Danny Hess here in San Francisco
is probably the leading light on that.
My goal is to make them
accessible for people.
We're not trying to
mass-produce surfboards here.
We're not trying to make as many as we can
as fast as we can.
I'm just focused on creating boards
that the craftsmanship
and quality is foremost.
One of the greatest motivations was
that I was taking salvaged wood,
and really just trying
to push the ball forward
and just see what alternative materials
that aren't surfboard materials
could make a successful surfboard.
Foam is just a dead piece of material.
It doesn't have a spring or a life to it.
Whereas wood is, you know,
you bend a piece of wood,
it springs right back to it.
Surfboards right now are not sustainable
except for wooden surfboards.
And we need to move millions
and millions of people
towards products like those
that are built to last,
built from dramatically
sustainable materials.
Materials that actually sequester carbon,
you know, out of the air and lock it away
in the surfboard under your feet.
Just thinking about the materials
that go into the surfboards
that we use is really important
because I don't want to
be surfing a surfboard
that has to be replaced every year.
The wood kind of is the starting point
and dictates what kind of
board we're gonna build.
I use a lot of different
locally sourced salvaged wood
from walnut to redwood, cypress,
all kinds of different wood.
The wood that I'm
building this board out of
is pretty special wood.
It's out of an old Victorian
from San Francisco.
So I select the pieces that
are gonna be appropriate,
bring that into the shop here.
And I use the chop saw to cut to length.
The panels start out pretty
raw. The edges are rough.
There's not a true
straight edge on anywhere.
And so I use the Festool track saw
that goes into the track,
and cuts incredibly accurate straight line
through the panel of wood.
And then I'm taking
those two separate pieces
and gluing them together
to create the panel
that will become the surfboard.
Once I create the panels,
I template the outline of the board
into the top of those panels.
So you end up with essentially the outline
of the surfboard in a
flat panel of redwood.
After that, I take that to the band saw
and rough cut the
outline of the surfboard.
What I'm doing is creating a top panel,
a bottom panel that are
the shape of the surfboard.
I also rough cut the frame
parts that create the interior
and rail parts of the surfboard.
And those are the banana-shaped pieces
that you see me cutting out.
Essentially, what they're doing
is creating a hollow cavity
inside the surfboard,
which removes a ton of weight,
but also makes them really strong.
So I create those frame parts.
And I take them onto the
table router and true them up
so that each part is
identical to each other.
And then I take it into the shaping room
and use a Japanese hand plane
as well as a belt sander.
That creates a nice true part
that has nice clean edges on it.
And I do that on all the parts
'cause you want to have clean pieces
that you can accurately cut and assemble.
I've made thousands of surfboards.
So I really feel like I've
developed a real trust in my eye.
It took me many, many
surfboards to get to that point
where I feel very confident
and comfortable with that.
Surfboards are essentially
a blend of art and science.
And you really have to do the
science part, the measuring,
the math, and everything at the beginning.
And then when you are
really into the curves,
and the complex radiuses of the board,
you really have to trust the art of it.
About 2,000 boards into it,
I started feeling like I just know
what this needs to look like.
But it took a lot of measuring
and concentrating to get to that point.
So the rocker is super fundamental part
of what makes the surfboard work.
It's the bottom curve of the surfboard.
If you have a flat surfboard,
it's just gonna go really fast,
but the nose is gonna poke,
and you're gonna go over the front.
If you have a really rockered surfboard,
it's just gonna push water and bog.
So you need to have a accurate curve.
So to create that curved frame,
I take those two interior frame parts,
and I roll glue between them.
I use this 10 minute
cure time really fast,
expanding polyurethane glue.
It's really amazing stuff,
but it kicks really fast.
So when you roll it out,
all your clamps are ready,
your parts are ready, you're ready.
And you throw it in the
mold, clamp it down,
and just run those clamps
around it really fast.
It sits in that mold for two
hours under all that pressure.
Then you pull all the clamps
off and it holds that curve.
A lot of wooden surfboards back in the day
were made from big blocks of wood,
and they would carve all that wood out.
So there's all this wasted
wood in the nose and tail.
Whereas with this, I'm
maximizing the use of the wood
that I'm using and
bending it into the curve,
which I think creates a much
stronger surfboard, the frame.
And also just is way more efficient,
you're not wasting any of the wood.
And all wooden surfboard is gonna beat
a surfboard that's made
from petroleum materials
any day, all day.
It's gonna outlast it.
It's gonna outperform it.
So I wanna make sure to give Danny
the props that he deserves.
His boards will be around
for hundreds of years
because they are tough,
because they don't break,
and they have great performance.
People are gonna want to keep
them and keep them around.
For the next step,
I take it into the shaping room.
The shaping room was designed
with really specific side lights.
I take it in there,
and strip all the glue off to
just get it all cleaned up.
I fine-tune it with my power planer
to clean up all the edges.
And then I take the power planer
and I put the foil into the frame.
The foil is,
if you think about the way
an airplane wing looks,
if you look at the profile
of it, it's elliptical.
Surfboards have a foil to them
just as an airplane wing does.
So you're putting that
foil into the bottom
and the top of that frame.
And that gives you a
refined internal panel piece
that you take back into the rocker bed,
and then take the deck panel,
which is a full panel of wood,
and bend that back into
the rocker bed with glue,
and clamp it all up all the way down.
Each piece is different.
When you try and do 'em
all at the same time,
they can crack and break,
and they become really temperamental.
You're just asking too
much out of the wood.
When you do it in steps like that,
you're able to really manipulate the wood
in a way that you wouldn't, if
you really tried to force it.
At this point, I've
glued together the deck,
the interior frame, and
the bottom of the board.
And it's essentially
looking like a surfboard.
It has the rough outline of a surfboard.
And that's when you start
laying your master template on there.
And that creates your guide points
for really drawing the curve.
Every shaper has their master templates
and the templates that they've created
over just many years of
evolving their designs.
And this one is a
template I call The Bella.
It's named after a friend's daughter.
The marks that I'm marking
on the deck of the surfboard
basically dictate the width
that the surfboard needs to be.
And then you're marking the
nose and tail dimensions.
Those dimensions are all super important
to create a really nice blending curve
that is pleasing to your eye.
At this point, I really sharpen my tools.
Especially on old salvaged redwood,
you need to have really tuned sharp tools.
And so I'll take out my sharpening blocks,
and really put some time
into getting razor sharp.
At that point, you have your shape set.
You have your length set,
you have your width set,
and you have all your
other dimensions set.
So from there, I take up the power planer
and really start truing up the outline
to the shape that the board's gonna be.
And once I true up the
outline of the board,
I flip it over and sand out the bottom
with my Festool sander.
And that really evens the whole bottom out
and blends it all.
From there, I map out my
rail bands on the bottom,
which are the curve of
the rail of the surfboard.
And I take the power planer again,
and just start putting that rail band in.
So it's from sharp edge to soft edge,
to sharper edge from nose to tail.
And you bring that in until
you feel the right curvature.
Then I take the Japanese block plane,
and I really tune that rail.
I remove any little ridge.
And then I lift it up.
And the underarm test is
the true test of shaper.
Like, you put it under your arm
and you feel that bottom edge.
And you know when it gets to
the point where it's right.
Then I take my sanding stick,
and I just shape in and blend in
all those little rough edges
that are left from the power
tools and the block plane.
And then I flip it over onto the deck,
and start taking the
material out of the deck.
That process is removing
a lot of material.
And once I get that to
the point that I want it,
I take the Festool sander,
and really blend in all
those rough shaving marks.
Then I'm using the power planer
to blend the top rail
into the bottom rail.
I'm putting that curve into
the board at that point.
And essentially, this is
the point where it's gone
from becoming a block
of wood to a surfboard.
And then I sand it,
fine-tuning those curves.
Then the shape of the board is done,
that it's finished, sanded,
it's ready for fin markings.
This one, is specifically, is a twin fin.
So I take my fin template,
mark the outline of the fin,
rough cut that out on the band saw,
and then true that up on
the stationary belt sander.
And then take that outline of
the fin into my shaping room,
and clamp it down on my shaping stand.
And take my angle grinder
and put in the foil,
which is that teardrop shape.
And then you have a fin
that's ready to be cut into
the bottom of that board.
And then I just put my
Hess stamp on the tail,
write the dimensions, which
are the length, the width,
the thickness of the board.
From there, I take my silk screen,
and stick it onto the deck of the board.
Silk-screen it on there, flip over,
do the same on the bottom.
And essentially, you've
got a finished board
that just needs to be sealed.
I have this specific
natural oil called Monocoat
that I use to seal board.
And it's a really amazing oil
that just penetrates
deep into the redwood,
and really creates a shell
or a skin that repels water.
I oil the fins at that point,
put my special glue on the very
base of the fin, the bottom,
and wedge it into the slot,
make sure the fins in
the exact right position.
And then essentially there you go,
you have a finished surfboard.
So at this point, the board's done,
and you just have to be patient,
wait for the oil to dry, the fins to dry.
And then I usually get so excited.
I just paddle out in
whatever waves I can find,
and just 'cause I know
I wanna feel the board,
I wanna feel how it moves to the water,
and that's the best part.
As soon as you kind of
baptize the surfboard,
you feel how it pushes under waves.
And you know as soon as
you paddle for a wave,
it engages, it catches the
wave smoothly, quickly.
And that first bottom
turn tells you so much
in terms of how that board's gonna work.
'Cause each board has its own personality.
That's such an exciting part
because there's so much anticipation.
I have this idea, I wanna make
this surfboard work this way
for this specific wave.
And then that moment of
truth, yes, it works!
That's the best feeling.
Surfboard builders like Danny Hess
are not just a symbol of
sustainability for our sport,
they're the absolute pinnacle, right?
Our hope is that the rest
of the surfboard industry
can adopt some of those same practices
that Danny and others have,
particularly with wooden surfboards,
and incorporate them into
the mass-producer for it.
So that we're dramatically
lowering the impact
that they're making,
and hopefully even leaving a
positive legacy in their wake.